[Music]
so starting with the objective part with
the facts the United States is a country
which is among the least equal in the
world according to Claire Suisse which
is a Swiss bank and not some kind of
crazy left-wing organization we are
second in the world in wealth inequality
after the Russian Federation in the
United States since the 1980s basically
90% of the American population has seen
no improvement in either wealth or
income almost all of the improvement of
wealth and income has been in the top
10% and most of that's been in the top
1% and most of that has been in the top
point one percent and most of that has
been in the top point zero one percent
which means that not only are people not
moving forward objectively but the way
they experience the world and this is
very powerful is that other people are
on top so if you and I have the same
thing over the course of 30 years but we
watch as our neighbor suddenly has 20
times as much we're not going to say Oh
everything's fine because we have the
same we're gonna say gosh our neighbor
has more than we do and has so much more
than we do
he could probably reach in and take
everything we have away which is of
course true and that's the condition
that people call oligarchy so the
politics of inevitability says the
market has to lead to democracy and
therefore there's no reason to correct
for what the market does if you don't
correct what the market does if you
don't support trade unions if you don't
build up some kind of a welfare state if
you don't support public education and
so on then you're gonna have a situation
where citizens spread apart and wealth
and spread apart and income which is
which is what's happening and that in
turn may be the most powerful way that
the politics of inevitability breaks
into the politics of eternity because if
there is massive inequality of wealth
and income individuals and families no
longer think I've got a bright future
they no longer believe and this is
something mr. Trump got right even if he
has no solution and he's making things
worse on purpose they no longer believe
in the American Dream and they're
correct not to do so if
you were born in 1940 your chances of
doing better than your parents art were
about 90 percent if you're born in 1980
your chances are about one and two and
it keeps going down so wealth inequality
means the lack of social advance means a
totally different horizon I means that
you see life in a completely different
way you stop thinking time is an arrow
which is moving forward to something
better and you start thinking hmm maybe
the good old days were better maybe we
have to make America great again and you
get caught in these nostalgic loops you
start thinking it can't be my fault that
I'm not doing better so whose fault is
it
and then the clever politicians instead
of providing policy for you provide
enemies for you they provide language
for you with which you can explain why
you're not doing so well they blame the
other whether it's the Chinese or the
Muslims or the Jews or the blocks or the
immigrants and that allows you to think
okay time is a cycle things used to be
better but other people have come and
they've taken things away from me
that's how the politics of inevitability
becomes the politics of eternity wealth
inequality income inequality or one of
the major channels by which that happens
so one of the fundamental problems with
our American right-wing politics of
inevitability is that it generates
income and wealth inequality and it
explains away income and wealth
inequality and so you get this cycle
where objectively people are less and
less well-off and subjectively we keep
telling ourselves this is somehow okay
because in the grand scheme of things
this is somehow necessary when it's not
[Music]